let's go back to the phones I know there
are lots and lots of people holding why
don't we go to our caller from the 585
area code caller from 585 you're on the
air
hi is this me that's you who's this hi
this is James from Rochester New York
all right go ahead James but big fan of
your show
thank you yes all right
so I called to ask in this day and age
administration in class it's it's hard
for somebody who identifies as a
Democrat or a progressive or liberal etc
whatever terminology somebody likes it
wants us to know what's the most
important things for us to be focused on
and I'm asking ya in the context of it's
a given that voting is very important
whether this administration in place
it's hard to know is there anything else
that we should really be focused on
besides just voting for example I don't
I don't get the impression that this is
an administration that would be
receptive to core responses to getting
emails or letters etc because it doesn't
seem like there's the most basic
structures really functioning in this
administration questions for example the
GPA I hear about the EPA all the time
right putting down regulation so now
they're you know they're actually
against environmental protection James I
don't mean to rush you but what was that
what's what's your question today well I
mean with this administration they don't
you know the government doesn't seem
console you know what do we really focus
on to start voting I don't think they'd
be responsive to getting emails and yeah
you're right they don't select a
functioning government altogether right
yeah so I would not waste my time
writing letters to the White House I
would certainly not do that I would vote
and then I would try to work on issues
that don't depend on the Oval Office
doing one thing or the
you can work at the local level you can
work at the state level you can work on
issues like you know I think ultimately
the net neutrality the overturning of
the net neutrality repeal I think
ultimately will fail but that's
something where you know you can Lobby
Congress but yeah I would not waste my
time writing letters to the White House
that that's not going to go anywhere is
there anything specific that you have
really recommend in the young
progressives to be focused on right now
besides just building I think the meta
issues right so campaign finance media
ownership and net neutrality an economic
system that is more fair I think and
climate change really are sort of like
the four the four meta issues right now
if I if I wanted to say I want to have
like the the highest level impact so we
think about that James thank you so much
really appreciate the call